bon merde t'as raison hervé hervé oui
hervé revenez à venir hervé excusez-moi
j'ai oublié de vous demander un truc
ses toiles
j'habite en charge
seth walsh à cette loi de chasse la
dernière fois c'est le jouet et
jean-pierre la dernière fois c'est hervé
bourges car partie en étant de chats
mais je crois qu'il a touché un ami
depuis je crois qu'il est bon ce n'est
plus je suis plus cher de l'heure et
c'est un jeu c'est un jeu et alors il
faut que je fasse quoi tu touches la
[ __ ] d'un mec ça devient de chat voilà
mais il faut le faire discrètement les
arbitres mais tu as une minute un sinon
torres xavi toute ta vie
attention c'est moi et garde sa guise
non non c'est pas valide et tapas du
chaabi tu le dis si tu es déjà bitton
touchant vie devant nous c'est mon papa
jean pierre
le droit
et
une cote au nom de carrière sont
maintenant ça tire je mal
m
c'est chabat sa bâche habite ce genre
ait un seul avec maman cherche à cha cha
on a eu un chercheur disney louis bien
des dialogues chabat mais la menace rôde
ap avoir touché son père non non non
donc tu donnes tu peux pas toucher le
cadre art tu dois toucher un autre
garçon ouais je sais bien
ces vignes le soir
bon quand tu le sors il faut plus le
chapitre à mende
et si tu peux pas être chatin tech
habite et ça devrait toucher son père
tout touché avant toi à moi de mai linh
la petite mimine
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe je suis vieux
schnock aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe cartouches
habite à la cartonnerie de la gueule si
c'est toi quel chat tu connais c'est
vous le sommes mais non je connais pas
mais si tu touches la [ __ ] de tempête et
puis c'est lui qu'elle soit latine
etienne etienne
alors on y va
et oui le chat le charme abandonnent
chaque petite touche habite de quelqu'un
et cetera le chasser seul quaden
ancien
alors karch habitent ces bouts de charge
et ocha tu as eu non pas du tout ce
n'est pas imbécile irdjen regard de
jeunes très vite avec ses habitudes va
toucher la [ __ ] d'un mec si l'huile
charpy n'empêche un autre va jouer
affirmé bojan cebin résultat qu'on va
s'acheter quelques uns n'ont pas un chat
on s'en fout je cherche la tête de
mcdonald's a cédé pendant tout chez sa
mère après tout le temps de rendre tous
chez sa mère chez sa mère j'attends déjà
touchée une autre fille ça sera la
chasse dakar
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu